So let's now go to another interesting interview
that Barack Obama did over the weekend.
Barack Obama was interviewed with 60 Minutes.
It was crazy, just like Trump.
Former President Obama walked out of the interview
abruptly as soon as he was asked the real
question.
I'm kidding.
Obviously, he didn't do that.
Unlike Donald Trump, who did do that a few
weeks ago, Barack Obama sat there and just
answered the questions he was asked.
We might not like every answer he gave, but
he just answered the questions.
Unlike Donald Trump, who had to abort the
interview and walk out on Leslie Stahl.
But I have some clips I do want to look at
with you.
And what I found fascinating about this interview
is that Barack Obama is talking about Trump
as if he's a problem child who misbehaves
and he's sort of struggling to deal with a
child.
It reminded me of a second grade teacher explaining
to the parents that, listen, what what little
Donny is doing in class.
It's not OK.
But I need to talk to you about what's going
on at home to really have a chance at fixing
it.
It felt like that type of a conversation.
Let's take a look at a little little bit of
it and then discuss what are these false claims
of widespread election fraud doing to our
country right now, the president doesn't like
to lose and never admits loss.
I'm more troubled by the fact that other Republican
officials who clearly know better are going
along with this are humoring him in this fashion.
Little Donny doesn't like to lose or admit
he lost.
But President Obama pointing out, as I've
been doing for some time now, that the problem
is not Trump alone.
It's Republicans around Trump and voters in
this case.
Because if every Republican simply said, Don,
come on, Joe Biden won Joe Biden's president
elect, you've got to move on.
We would have a very different scenario if
right wing media did the same, this wouldn't
now be dragging out into what is almost week
three at this point in time with 86 percent
of Trump assets believing Joe Biden didn't
legitimately win.
And we'll talk about this.
The idea here is the problem isn't really
Trump.
The problem is the Republican Party.
You could have a Trump.
If Trump tried to run as a Democrat, it would
have gone nowhere.
Trump ran as a Republican.
And I'm not going back to that debunked quote
that that's not even a real quote from Trump
from 20 years ago.
The reason Trump became president is because
he ran as a Republican.
It wouldn't have worked in the Democratic
Party.
And the problem is Republicans to a great
degree.
And we will talk about that.
But let's continue with this interview.
It is one more step in delegitimizing not
just the incoming Biden administration, but
democracy generally.
And that's a dangerous path.
We would never accept that out of our own
kids behaving that way if they lost.
I mean, if my daughters and any kind of competition
pouted and then accused the other side of
cheating when they lost, when there was no
evidence of it, we'd scold them.
This is just perfect.
And I'd actually go further.
It's not just children that get scolded for
acting the way Trump is acting.
Trump is acting like a child.
I've played in sports leagues as an adult.
I've played in soccer leagues.
I've played in dodgeball.
We had a huge dodgeball performance where
The David Pakman Show charity dodgeball team
won the tournament.
But imagine we had lost.
And imagine that we started saying the refs
rigged it.
We actually won.
I mean, even adults who behave this way in
any kind of competitive event would be asked
to leave.
And that is what Donald Trump is doing.
And then Barack Obama also pointed out that
there's been huge normalization of insanity
in the last few years.
And he likens Trump to a strongman dictator.
You know, I think that there has been.
This sense over the last several years that
literally anything goes and is justified in
order to get power and, you know, that's not
unique to the United States.
There are strongmen and dictators around the
world who think that I can do anything to
stay in power.
I can kill people, I can throw them in jail,
I can run phony elections, I can suppress
journalists.
But that's not who we're supposed to be.
And one of the signals, I think, that Joe
Biden needs to send to the world is that,
no, those values that we preached and we believed
in and subscribed in, we still believe now,
literally, as this interview is wrapping up
on 60 Minutes, Donald Trump took to Twitter
and tweeted this humiliating screed, quote,
Why does the fake news media continuously
assume that Joe Biden will ascend to the presidency?
Not even allowing our side to show which we
are just getting ready to do, how badly shattered
and violated our great constitution has been
in the twenty twenty election.
It was attacked, perhaps like never before,
from large numbers of poll watchers that were
thrown out of vote counting rooms in many
of our states to millions of ballots that
have been altered by Democrats only for Democrats
to voting after the election was over to using
radical left owned Dominion voting systems
turned down by Texas and many others because
it was not good or secure.
Those responsible for the safeguarding of
our Constitution cannot allow the fake results
of the 2020 mail in election to stand.
The world is watching completely humiliating.
I mean, it's we're going to go through the
lies in that in the next segment.
But this is a humiliating tragedy that the
United States is going through right now.
We all we can do is put one foot in front
of the other one day at a time and get to
January 20th.
We really can't do anything else at this point.